sit up right there
see right there Chad Dorman
all right this uh charges came out today
for you all right I'm gonna read through
these if you got any questions give it
to me at the end all right all right
looks like count one
uh aggravated murder
it says honor about June 15 2023 in the
county of Claremont uh didn't know he
purposely with prior calculation design
cause of death
and violation of higher rise code 290301
aggravated murder unclassified felony
I'm victim under the age of 13.
all right count two
grand jury further finds the president
that Chad C Dorman on about June 15 2023
County of Claremont did purposely with
prior calculation to design cause of
death of violation of a higher rise code
0.01 aggravated murder
victim under the age of 13.
count three aggravated murder Chad C
Dorman on about June 15 2023 in the
county of Claremont there purposely with
prior calculation design cause of death
of
um they're at their initials so I want
everything this violate some higher
biased code
290321 aggravated murder unclassified
felony victims under age of 13.
well looks like count four aggravated
murder 290301 B section chats he doing
on about June 15 2023 County of
Claremont did purposely cause the death
of
while committing or attempting to commit
or a while fleeing immediately after
committing or attempting to commit the
offense of kidnapping and violation of
via Revised Code 290301 B aggravated
murder unclassified felony victims under
age of 13.
count five aggravated murder said Chad C
John the doorman on her about June 15
2023 in the county of Clermont
did purposely cause the death of while
committing or attempting to commit while
fleeting immediately after committing or
attempting to commit the offense of
kidnapping and violation of a higher
rise code 290301 aggravated murder
unclassified felony
victim under the age of 13.
is here
for
four six seven
get them all screwed in here
count six uh
Chad C Dorman on our about June 15 2023
County of Claremont did purposely cause
it depth uh while committing the or
attempting to commit a wet fleeing
immediately after committing or
attempting to commit the offensive
kidnapping violation of 29032-1 victim
under the age of 13.
looks like there's also
a total of nine counts of the aggravated
murder
there's seven counts of kidnapping I'm
going to read these here for you too
I'm gonna read them too but I got to
count ten kidnapping F1 with
specifications grand jury further 100
chancy doing on about June 15 23 23 in
the county of Claremont did by force
threader deception removed from the
place where he was found a restrained
the liberty of him with the purpose of
terrorizing or inflicting serious
physical harm upon
blank or another violation Revised Code
2905.01 kidnapping the felony the first
degree
the firearm specifications on all those
counts as well
um count 11.
June 15 2023 in the county of Claremont
did by force thread or the steps removed
from the place here she was found
restrained from the liberty of him for
the purpose of terrorizing and
inflicting serious physical harm upon
initials or another violation of higher
price code
2905.01 kidnapping the felony of the
first degree firearm respect
count 12 kidnapping F1
grand jury foreign
about June 15 2023 County of Claremont
did by force threader reception removed
from the place where he or she was found
from Liberty of him or purposes of
terrorizing inflicting physical harm or
another in violation of the revised code
290501 kidnapping firearm specification
2941.145
Channel 13 kidnapping
uh June 15 2023
the county of Claremont did by Forest
threader accepts removed the initials
from the person he was found restrained
the liberty of of her for the purpose of
terrorizing inflicting serious physical
harm
upon or another violation of Our Lives
go to kidnapping felony of the first
degree
2905.01 firearm specification
Channel 14 is another kidnapping Chad's
he doing on about June 15 2023 in county
of Claremont theater by Forester
deception removed
from the place he was found a restrained
Liberty of him for purpose of facility
in the commission of a felony to with an
aggravated murder 290301 or flight there
and after in a violation of Revised Code
290501 kidnapping the felony the first
degree of firearm specifications
count 15 is also kidnapping the grand
jury Plaza Chad see dormant on her about
June 15 2023 in Clermont County dead by
forest threat or deception removed from
the place where he was found or
restraint Liberty of him with the
purpose of facilitating the commission
of felony to with aggravated murder
or flight there in a violation of a
higher Revised Code 2050182 kidnapping
the stunning the first degree of the
firearm specifications
on count 16 kidnapping
June 15 2023 in the county of Claremont
did my Forester deception remove the
initials from the place were here she
was found restrain the liberty of him
and the purpose of facilitating the
commission of the founding to it
aggravated murder
farmer specification count 17 another
kidnapping grand jury further finder
presented that chats he's doing on about
June 15 2023 in the county of Claremont
did by force thread receptionally
removed from the place she was found to
restrain the Libya of her with the
purpose of the facilitating the
commission of the felony to with
aggravated murder
290301a for flight their violation for
the higher Revised Code 290501
kidnapping to filling the first degree
foreign specification
uh count 18 Florence assault felony two
grand jury further refines that chassis
Dorman honor about June 15 2023 in the
county of Claremont didn't only cause or
attempt to cause physical harm to their
initials by means of deadly weapon or
dangerous ordinance with firearm
violation advise code 2030182 Florence
assault felony of the second degree
it's a firearm specifications count 19
Florence assault
about June 15 23 23 in the county of
Claremont didn't only cause serious
physical harm to their initials and
violation higher Revised Code
29031-1
second degree firearm specifications
count 20 20 assault
on about June 15 2023 in the county of
Claremont didn't only cause or attempt
to physical harm to their initials by
means of deadly weapons or dangerous
ordinance to which firearm violation the
higher price go to 20311 Florence
assault felony the second degree firearm
specification count 21 Columbus assault
grand jury further finds that chatsey
doing are about June 15 2023 in the
county of Claremont didn't only cause
serious physical harm to their initials
violations of higher advised code
290311 valence assault felony the second
degree also the foreign specification
signed by the grand jury panel and
another prosecutor
nine aggravated murder charges
looks like seven kidnapping charges and
four fluency assault charges
you understand
okay
yeah